it's been a rallying cry since the
police killing of George Floyd
protesters activists and some city
officials calling for police departments
across the u.s. to be defunded it's
painted in huge block letters on city
streets from Washington to Wisconsin
but how would it work some who support
the idea want to strip all police
funding and dissolve entire departments
but other advocates want to reallocate
some but not all money away from police
departments and funneled some of it to
training civilians to do some of the
jobs police have always done and have
looked at ways we can shift the response
away from armed police officers into a
more appropriate response for mental
health calls for some domestic violence
calls for health related issues the
cities of Eugene and Springfield Oregon
have a service which does just that
it's called cahoots in some instances
instead of police dispatchers in Eugene
and Springfield send out cahoots teams
to civilians in each a medic and a
trained crisis worker to respond to what
they call non criminal calls we can
respond for welfare checks we can check
on folks who maybe need some mediation
if there's an argument we can deescalate
if someone is in a neighborhood kind of
just acting odd we can just check on
them and make sure they don't need
anything
evany Morgan says cahoots helped more
than 20,000 people in those situations
last year alone with they're
non-combative unarmed approach I've seen
police presence agitate some folks and
they get a little more intense for
whatever their experience has been when
they see us they know that we're just
there to talk and if they tell us to
leave we'll leave some police advocates
say that approach simply doesn't work
when you're walking up to a potentially
dangerous domestic dispute you think
that you are going to send an unarmed
therapist or social worker to the scene
of a domestic dispute where somebody has
beaten up their partner shot their
partner or committed some act of
violence against them and you think that
you're going to send somebody there with
they're required equipment to protect
themselves and the innocent person that
their response help
that's folly advocates for defunding
police say that money can be used to pay
for schools hospitals housing and mental
health services in poorer marginalized
communities all of which they say helps
increase safety but one police chief is
worried about what could suffer the
first thing will go will be training all
the things we need to make sure that we
have the properly trained and
professional police that that our law
that our communities deserve